[Musique]
si vous avez circuler à paris cet été
sans doute avez vous constaté les
travaux entrepris pour installer des
couloirs de bus protégés sur les grands
axes comme le boulevard sébastopol où la
rue de rivoli notamment la nouvelle
municipalité veut ainsi faire plus de
place aux transports en commun et aux
vélos et - à la voiture individuelle les
verts y voient une vraie urgence et un
petit accident survenu hier à yves
contassot élu vert à la mairie a servi
opportunément d'illustration vanessa
rouet et mathias il couloirs élargis
nouveau plan de circulation à paris
pourtant personne n'est à l'abri d'un
chauffard hier midi c'est yves contassot
l'adjoint vert à la mairie de paris qui
en a fait les frais alors qu'il sortait
d'une réunion consacrée justement au
problème des motos qui circulent dans
les couloirs de bus l'élu écologiste a
été renversée par un motard
symbole de la nécessité de partager
l'espace entre des véhicules qui vont
relativement vite comme des motos des
voitures et ceux qui vont plus lentement
les vélos les rollers les piétons depuis
les transports en commun et évidemment
les autres véhicules type d'accès
véhicules de secours
donc il faut re partager la voirie et
que ce ne soit plus le la jungle au
profit des seules voitures et moteurs
cet accident illustre le problème de
cohabitation plus que difficile entre
les différents véhicules à paris cet été
la mairie avait pourtant décidé d'agir
pour l'instant sept kilomètres de
couloirs sur 41 ont été aménagés pour
normalement être interdite aux voitures
particulières comme aux motos des
couloirs plus larges et protégé par un
trottoir
non moi je trouve ça plus sécurisant
qu'avant et je trouve que même le même
si à des motos ont fait et font
attention elle en général c'est que les
voitures à ce combat d'attention et
surtout des voitures se garent et
surtout les gens qui ouvrent leur
portière fait son nom je me mets
vraiment pas tellement ce que j'ai pu
premier avec les voitures clairement
avec les voitures et les bus quoi pour
yves contassot les douleurs au dos
persiste le motard lui a le bras cassé
il en est quitte pour trois mois
d'interruption de travail
[Musique]